All right. Back after a couple of weeks of
hiatus. Is hatred mail? What is Harriet Mail?
It is when a professional voiceover artist
does interpretive readings of the hate mail
that I receive. Here's a quick reminder.
Why don't you take some hydroxyl chloroquine
for that Trump derangement syndrome?
Hey, tree memo written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because freedom.
All right. A lot in this week's Hatred Mail.
Let's listen to it first and then discuss
and think about it.
Nice yarmulke, Davin. Of course, Packman,
as a Jew, Hispanic is not a race. It is an
ethnicity. And you're Jewish. But Argentina,
white boy. Get the Jews out. Seriously? David
Pakman is a Jew, a denier of Christ. Don't
be a greedy Jew and use your dog as a ploy.
Come on, bro. We're better than that. As Progressive's.
So Hispanic is not a race, but rather an ethnicity.
But I'm Jewish, but I'm from Argentina, so
I'm a white boy. But Jews should leave. Well,
I guess if Jews are white, then I don't need
to leave.
It's kind of a weird amalgam of xenophobia
and various misunderstandings. I love the.
We're better than that. As Progressive's the
viewer, I guess, sort of implying that they
are part of the progressive crowd, just another
progressive who says Jews get out. Yeah. Somehow
I think that this person maybe gaslighting
and what I want to remind you is the best
way to fight hatred autism is to use the coupon
code.
Hatra at 40. When you get a membership, join
Packman dot com. H h t r i o t for zero you
save 40 percent and patriots cry every time
that coupon code is used at join packman dot
com.